yeah I just want to say it is so not my
knife all right
I am wondering did this bit of writerly
news come to your attention a couple of
years ago or maybe I should say can
anyone even remember anything else that
happened in 2016 let's go back past
November to March the novelist and poet
Jim Harrison passed away in March 2016
at the age of 78
Harrison sometimes work as a
screenwriter here in Los Angeles mostly
adapting the novels and novellas that he
had written and hanging out with pals
like Jack Nicholson like Bill Murray
John Huston the New York Times obituary
for Jim Harrison says that in his
writing Harrison with ardent abandoned
explored the natural world the life of
the mind and the pleasures of the flesh
obviously some of that ardent abandon
spilled over into his life Jim Harrison
once described having dinner with Orson
Welles in which they shared a half pound
of beluga caviar with a bottle of Stoli
nyah a whole salmon and sorrel sauce
sweetbreads on quote a miniature leg of
lamb the whole thing with five wines
desserts cheeses ports and a chaser of
cocaine for many years beside my writing
desk I've had a quote from Harrison tape
to the wall a quote about writing that
gives us permission not to be cool as we
write to not protect ourselves from
feeling what we feel and to not protect
the audience either he says I like grits
I like love and death I'm tired of irony
as we know from the Russians a lot of
good fiction is sentimental the novelist
who refuses sentiment refuses the full
spectrum of human behavior and then he
just dries up I would rather give full
vent to human love and disappointments
and take a chance on being corny than
die a smartass I could involve with the
Academy Nicholl fellowship competition
for over a decade now and one thing I've
noticed is the scripts that rise to the
top of the pile usually aren't that cool
usually there's something fairly raw in
the work something hard to say something
uncomfortably true a subject that's a
little impolite or unwanted that
nonetheless needs to be said and I
promise you this committee does not set
out with a specific goal to end up with
10 scripts it would please Jim Harrison
but we do have guidelines that I think
tip the Nicholl fellowship toward
stories that have meaning we ask of
ourselves does the story have an
original premise does this script make
you feel that the writer is taking you
on a journey does the story connect with
you emotionally whether it's a comedy or
a drama or another genre does the writer
have a distinctive and original voice or
do you feel that you've seen this movie
before does the story have vivid
characters who each speak in their own
voice do you want to know what happens
to them does the story propel you
forward and do your main characters take
the actions that propel the story are
the themes of the story
thought-provoking across genres is the
story about something that might provoke
a discussion when you finish reading the
script even if it has flaws do you still
feel that there's something special
about it even if it has flaws is the key
phrase when our committee convenes we
aren't looking for perfect scripts
crafts yes
perfection absolutely not we're not even
really seeking scripts we're seeking
interesting writers
challenged people who may not yet have
nailed every aspect of screenwriting but
who have something that they absolutely
have to say we're looking for writers
who make us feel they can't be silenced
who have something on their minds who
won't settle in comfortably into a
commercial field of cookie cutter
entertainments but who will keep
bringing up the important subjects the
uncool emotions the stories that
encompass the full spectrum of all human
behavior
rewriting can always improve a script
that isn't yet perfect but nothing you
learn in film school supplies the
essential qualities of soul and heart
and courage and daring that made this
year's screenplays rise to the top of
the Nicholl fellowship competition so if
you're writing right now dig deep this
year our nickel committee Reds 6895
screenplays which through multiple
readings were narrowed down to 349
quarter-finalists out of rich rows 151
semi-finalists the semi-finalists
scripts were read by members of the
Academy across all branches again
multiple times when we had 10 finalists
our committee met for several hours
discussing all 10 writers and at the end
of a long impassioned meeting that
involved neither a beluga caviar nor
cocaine we settled on four winning
entries three individual writers plus
one writing team I'm going to ask
Jennifer Nelson to introduce those
writers to you Jennifer is a talented
and highly valued part of the nickel
committee she's a member of the short
film and animation branch she directed
Kung Fu Panda and Kung Fu Panda 2 for
which she was nominated for an Oscar
she's the only the second woman who's
ever been nominated for an animation
Oscar this year she directed the
live-action film the darkest mind and
she has directed tonight's live reading
of scenes from the Academy Nicholl
fellowship screenplays for 2018 please
welcome Jennifer you now